Conte is real quick yes I it was early
2000s and I had been doing my place for
a long time and I got a chance to do it
one here for the first time I regret
saying you have to do it in LA you have
to do it in LA so I do it at the
Wilshire Ebell theatre everybody shows
up all the agents show up and it was a
big moment for me they had offers for me
to do things and it never happened to me
before so I'm driving home and I'm in
tears I'm so grateful so thankful to God
and I hear your song for the first time
a moment like this yes and that thing
told me up so I'm trying to drive and
cry there's a moment like this I've been
waiting for so you know you don't know
each other men like years later we run
into each other that's such a life is so
beautiful I love that about life you
never know what is gonna affect you the
domino effect that will have its service
I will not stop talking until you
subscribe to my youtube channel that's
right and I could talk a lot seriously
not gonna stop yep still here not going
anywhere I see you don't walk away from
this